you saw photos of the wedding it looked
absolutely beautiful
who between the two of you cried more
oh she did yeah you know i saw you know
i teared up a little bit
you know i might have shed a tier two or
three or four or five or six or seven
she definitely grabbed me you had some
some really fun friends
at the wedding darius rucker kathleen
gifford who parties heartbreak
i don't know they're kind of running
neck and neck a little buzz then a
little toasted
as for the next big celebration that
would be a baby shower
did any names picked out for the new
allen baby yet and i got a name
i wanted to name her arya stark allen
because i'm a huge gamer brooms fan
she was like nah i didn't ask it wait oh
jeez but what i'm gonna do no matter
what we name this kid
her nickname's gonna be arya stark i'ma
just start calling it out
are you sure yeah jimmy finds all kinds
of inspiration being a dad
now i wanna talk to you about your book
my voice is a trumpet
what inspired this my children i wanted
to
leave them something other than just
music you know
so i wanted to have a book and words
that was written directly
for them you know be confident in
yourself it's okay to encourage other
people
okay to be kind so and it's also okay to
kind of you know stand up for yourself
as well
the 35 year old also just released a new
album betty james gold edition
which features collaborations with
country superstars and some of the
genres best emerging artists
color my playlist you know of artists
that i'm
fans of friends with women they're a
legend like
charlie pride tim mcgraw and brad
paisley or if they're a new artist like
you know breelan and latham warlock and
i just wanted to have
an album you know just full of music
that
i love inspired by artists from that my
grandmom loved that my father loved
all together